i'm just so happy to be back i'm so  thankful for this team  these guys carried us to an incredible  start and then they  be coming back in there i mean  i'm i don't want to get emotional aaron  i can't believe we're back this is crazy  i'm going to enjoy this tonight but  wow we still got four more to go dumb  nation this is  i'm gonna soak this in the night though  i can't believe it i really can't  believe it i'm just so happy to be back  i'm so thankful for this team  these guys carried us to an incredible  start and then they  be coming back in there i mean  i'm i don't want to get emotional aaron  i can't believe we're back this is crazy  i'm going to enjoy this tonight but  wow we still got four more to go dumb  nation this is  i'm going to soak this in the night  though i can't believe it i really can't  believe